the gondolas are the symbol of venice they
are recognizable all over the world and it
is a source of pride for everyone to
start the gondola especially for us
who are among the mountains and the symbol of
the city will be a tramontin and now
we are carrying out the
construction of  family
this falls under founded in 1884 we
are the fifth generation tramontina
seeing a tramontin water band for me
is a source of pride because they are beautiful
they have compared them to ferrari oscuro
tremonti is found dorsoduro in
foundation every saints and in the heart of the
city practical angels to
heyday there were so many sharks now there are
four of us left that we are also the
only ones trying to carry
on the traditional method my
name is matteo tamassia and I am a shipwright
or a builder of
wooden boats
[Music  ] I have been
collaborating with the tramontin company for
about 10 years to build le monde re
[Music]
a cylinder takes about three months the
carpentry  later there was another month
for the painting then there is the
carving part could be even a
thousand hours the tramontin gondola at the
sides in oak table
the structure in oak and elm the deck
in mahogany cherry walnut lime larch and
they are assembled with galvanized nails
avoiding stainless steel the gondola is
customized on the weight and
on the need for wedding favors for the
gondolier is customized a
little bit as an investor
the gondola differs from all
other wooden boats, let's say
substantially for the symmetry in
this way the gondolier is able to
better turn around the canals he had king
with an oar only the best point to
foresee venice is on a gondola
this is the doubt there is water is venice
so to sail on a rowing gondola
a rowing boat  the most beautiful magic
that can be in venice
[Music]
my sister and matteo feel the honor
and duty to carry on this
centenary tradition is not really
very easy, however, if we will
certainly do it
[Music]